y 18 días duró en el cargo del cuarto
ministro de salud de ecuador
rodolfo farfán renunció a menos de 80
días que concluya el gobierno de lenin
moreno az irregularidades en el plan de
vacunación no cesaron con el cambio el
ministro juan carlos ceballos quiero yo
del país con una causa abierta de
investigaciones por las listas secretas
en la fase cero de inoculación
el escándalo se destapa cuando concluye
el tiempo de una orden judicial que
obligaba el actual ministro de salud
hacer públicas las listas secretas que
no se conocieron y concluyó con la
renuncia irrevocable argumentando
razones personales
paralelamente se conoció una publicación
del medio digital en la posta de los
nombres que incluyen la primera dama
rocío moreno colaboradores del
presidente de la república el ministro
de defensa abogados conocidos rectores
universitarios y el coordinador de
campaña del candidato presidencial
guillermo lasso
entre otros la publicación de los
nombres cercanos del presidente
obligaron al ejecutivo nacional a
justificar la vacunación como un asunto
de seguridad nacional ante la condición
vulnerable y física de lenin moreno la
defensoría del pueblo reclaman la
transparencia de la vacunación cuando
apenas ha llegado al país 1,5 por ciento
de las 20 millones de dosis negociadas
luego de negarlo y esquivar el tema
presiones en contra del gobierno
continúan destapando el tema que se
mantiene en secreto